One last thing and we've been avoiding bringing this up until now,
but it's something you as an entrepreneur should know, it's a secret.
And it's a secret that we didn't even understand for a long time and that secret is
there are four types of startups and not knowing which type you are can really sink your company.
So we call this market type. It turns out that there really are four types of markets for startups.
One is existing market. Another is where you take a segment or re-segment an existing market.
Another is a new market and another is a clone market.
So let's take a look why this is important and then we'll give you the definition of each one.
It turns out that the type of market changes everything.
It changes your initial market size, how much it cost to enter the market,
what kind of launch you do with your product, it affects the type of competitive barriers you have,
and how you position or describe your product.
It affects your sales model. Are you going to hire direct sales? When do you hire them?
What kind of margins you should have or the profits?
How long it takes, that is the sale cycle and something called the chasm width,
which we'll take a look in a sec.
It also affects how much money you're going to need to raise
and how long it takes to get the profitability and then finally, it affects the types of customers
and what they're needs are and how long it takes to adapt?
So, what are the things this looks like is just a checklist of market type seems to affect everything.
What the heck can it be? So let's go a little further and define.